το πράγμα που τις τώσεις δυσκολήγες και το πρώτο των πράμα που σκέφτεσε και του
το είναι ένα τανακλαστικών είναι τουτή να κάμω να λύσω το πρόβλημα ούτε ν υπρώτη
σκέψη που κάνεις γιότι δεν έχει στην πολυτέλεια του χρόνο να σκεφτής ότι δήποτε άδλο
ο στόχος του είναι να λύσεις τα προβλήματα έχει προβλήματα πό πάρα πολλά της κλοκαιο
χρονίζουν κάποια δεχομένος να λύνων τους πιο εύκολα αλλά είναι η πρώτη σκέψη που πρρέπι
και πρώτη σκυψη που εγώ προσωπικά κα παμε λίγο να δο τη θεματο λογία το
υπουργείου και ξεκινώ από τη πούμε το νερό νερά και φέρος το νερό νεράκι δεν
το λέμε τώρα έχει μήνες που το λέμε και πρέπει να να θυμίσω για να
πω ότι για να διανίουμε σήμερα το τργεη τω έτος ανομβριας σημαίνει ότι έχουμε κάμει
πάρα πολλές ενέργειες για να συνεχίζουμε στο τριτο νέτος ανοβρίας να καλύπτουμε το εκατόν της
εκατο της ίδρευσης τα πράγματα είναι πάρα πολύ δύσκολα διότι αν πάρουμε και τα στατιστικά
διανίουμε της χειρότερες χρονιές που αποψηνανοβρίες ξαναπέρασε ναι κύπρος πολού σκύκλου ανομβρίας τούτος ενένας που
τους χειρότερους εμείς από την πρώτη στιμή δηλαδή ου με την ανάλιψη των καθικώντο το
πρώτο των πράγμα που εκάνουμε ήταν καταρχή να περάσουμε που το υπουργικόσυμβούλεο όλα τα έργα
τα οποία χρειάζεται να γίνουν για θεματα άδρλεψης γύδρευψης θεα να ταπαφορούντα στικά λήματα καιτα
λιπά το δεύτερο το οποίον κάναμε που ήταν ιδύσ κολύ χρονία διααποπέρσει επήραμε την πολύ
έτση δύσκολη να απόφαση να κάουμε περικοπές στους γεοργούς α ξεκινήσαμεμε περικοπές καταμέσον όλοντριντο της
εκατόν και συνεχίζουμε το επόμενο βήμα που εκάμαμε ήταν φυσικά να ενημερώσουμε τις βριξελλες που
ταν απαραίτητο να γίνει επροχωρήσαμε τς